مشاجي وعمره 53 سنه كان رايح على منزله
بحفله نقل جماعي ومتحمس لمشاهده مباراه
نصف النهائي بين الارجنتين وكرواتيا عندي
اشاره المرور اخبرهم السائق انه راح يتوقف
عشان يشتري شيء وبالفعل نزل السائق من
الحفله فشعر نشجع الارجنتيني بالاحباط
والحزن انه ما عاد هيلحق المباراه يعني بس
عاد ما كان منه الا انه قام وقاعد مكان
السائق واخذ الحفله ساق فيها وبالركاب
اللي فيها كمان واخذها مسافه كده اربع
كيلو متر وقف قريب من بيته ونزل منه ودخل
يتفرج على المباراه لكن الفرحه ما تمت
لانه بعد دقائق من دخوله للبيت جاءت
الشرطه وقبضت عليه لانه طبعا سائق الحافله
الاصلي بلغ عن اختطاف الحفله بالركاب في
كل الاحوال الرجل ما شاف المباراه
[موسيقى]